a passenger plane split in two
after it overshot the runway and fell 35
feet
into a gorge many have died and scores
injured some in serious condition
the plane was carrying 190 people
including 10
infants and seven crew members
both the pilot and co-pilot have lost
their lives
the plane landed during the heavy
monsoon rain that has lashed the state
of
kerala over the last 24 hours
the air india express flight which was
coming in from dubai
and was landing in the kalikat airport
quasi-court airport
around 7 40 7 45
that seems to have skidded off the
runway and we must remember it's a
tabletop runway
so it seems to have crossed that runway
and fallen into a ditch sort of a place
pictures of the crash site show very
heavy damage to the plane's fuselage
and the front part of the aircraft the
ill-fated air india express
flight was a repatriation one regular
commercial flights have been halted in
india
because of the coronavirus outbreak
there are reports of the aircraft making
several rounds trying to land
it made two failed attempts
well one thing i think you'd clearly
want to look at as a factor would be the
weather conditions
so if you have a wet runway
it automatically increases the stopping
distance somewhat
if there is standing water there is a
possibility
of what's called aquaplaning where the
aircraft tyres never break through the
water layer
they're effectively water skiing rescue
operations are hindered
due to the heavy rainfall the civil
aviation ministry
has ordered an inquiry into the accident